Gemütlich auf dem sofa chillen und dabei zusehen wie die hauptfigur der lieblingsserie, im wald erst verfolgt und dann getötet wird
Da bleibt einem doch das ein oder andere mal das popcorn
Im hals stecken denn bei einer richtig guten verfolgung sagt mit einem
solch bedauerlichen ende bleibt einem doch gar nichts anderes übrig als so richtig mitzufiebern dazu kursiert ein video der american chemical society
netz das zeigt was wir alle schon längst geahnt haben der zuschauer oder die zuschauer in eines horrorfilms fühlt sich tatsächlich
Ähnlich wie das opfer, im film selbst
Welche chemischen prozesse beim sterben und auch beim reinen zugucken eines mordfalles vom sofa aus in unserem gehirn ablaufen
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Stell dir vor jemand sagt ich ein mensch mit einer axt oder sonst jemand der nichts anderes will als dich umzubringen
Vielleicht ist es sogar noch dunkel und du kannst kaum etwas sehen
Im großen wald in dem du dich verirrt hast du weißt wohl dass du eigentlich keine
Möglichkeit hast deinen mörder zu entkommen ein echtes horrorszenario also aber so oder so ähnlich
Kennen wir es alle und zwar aus horror filme oder serien oder krimis und so weiter und so fort und die gefühle die wir dabei
Haben die eine sehr denen der mordopfer, im fernsehen oder im kino
also beziehungsweise derjenigen die das wirklich erleben das sagt zumindest das video der american chemical society
Also der amerikanischen fachgesellschaft für chemie das freie netz zugänglich ist die
überwiegende emotion ist eindeutig angst pure angst dafür sorgen die
Große drohende gefahr und der hohe schaden also der tod der daraus mit aller wahrscheinlichkeit
Resultieren wird zudem ist wohl auch nicht mit hilfe von
Außen zu rechnen dein puls und den blutdruck steigen seine pupillen erweitern sich und du stehst unter hochspannung dadurch kommt es zu einer aktivierung des
Nebennieren marx wodurch adrenalin ausgeschüttet wird dadurch wird für mit glykogen ein vielfach sogar abgebaut wird aus dem körper mehr energie
Zur verfügung steht laut american society of chemistry werden angst und adrenalin auf ähnliche weise aktiviert also sowohl
anzuschauen des horrorfilms als auch bei einem echten
Mordopfer beides ist in einem solch einem krass moment tatsächlich sehr wichtig für den menschlichen körper dieser
wirklich komplizierte chemische prozess führt dazu dass der organismus alarmiert ist sich bereit zu machen um zu reagieren beispielsweise
wegzulaufen raus aus der gefahrenzone das, zentrale nervensystem
leitet die signale an den thalamus weiter denn etwa sowie eine schaltzentrale
funktioniert von hier aus wird die info an anderen gehirnteile gesendet der körper macht sich bereit die alles entscheidende frage für den folgen entscheidungsprozess
lautet kampf oder flucht das stresshormon cortisol tut sein übriges dafür sicher ist aber ein lautes schreien dieses schreien
motiviert schneller zu laufen das pusht noch einmal deinen ganzen körper das schreien
Im film löst dann wiederum furchtbaren zuschauer oder der zuschauerin aus wie genau
Sich der direkte moment des sterbens dann anfühlt das wiederum ist noch
Weitgehend unerforscht wie sollte das auch gehen schließlich ist noch keiner der mir bekannten toten wieder auferstanden doch es gibt hier versuche dazu
demnach versiegt die gehirnaktivität während des sterbeprozess nicht allmählich sondern steigt noch einmal für kurze zeit deutlich an
das hat beispielsweise ein forschungsteam der university of michigan
2013 berichtet dieses ergebnis könnte gegebenenfalls auch die berichte von nahtoderfahrungen
Stützen das netzwerk nato der erfahrung schätzt dass etwa vier millionen menschen in deutschland schon mal so ein
Mysteriöses erlebnis hinter sich gebracht haben beispielsweise nach einem unfall in den berichten heißt es dann
So etwas wie es fühlt sich einfach an wie ein perfekter schlaf aber ohne träume andere
Berichten davon dass sie es eher wie ein leben nach dem tod empfunden haben beispielsweise von einer licht vision
Am ende des tunnels oder als eine art lebens finden in der medizin wird der zustand nachdem die atmung langsamer wird und das herz aufhört
zu schlagen als klinischer tod bezeichnet dann folgt der biologische tod alle organe und
Zellfunktionen sind erloschen und danach kann auch keiner mehr davon berichten wie es ist zu sterben doch die forschung kommt diesem moment immer
Näher wie wir gerade gehört haben wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier
ein abo aufsaugen vergessen nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Todbringende kinderlähmung ist zurück in europa ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran